CHRIS RAMSDALE:
Hello, and thank you
for coming out to this
year's Google I/O conference.
I'm Chris Ramsdale.
KATE VOLKOVA: I'm Kate Volkova,
software engineer on App Engine
team.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Yes.
And today, if you
didn't get a chance
to attend the keynote
session, there
was a lot of great
technologies that
were announced and talked about.
Android had a slew of amazing
technology that's coming out,
for both the consumer
and the developer.
Chrome had some
great advancements.
The Cloud Platform has
some great technologies
that were coming out.
And I'm happy to talk
about a few of those
as we go through
the session today.
So if you did get
to attend, you saw
that our director of product
management, Greg DeMichillie,
was using a demo application
called WalkShare, which
was an Android client
that was hooked up
to back-end services that
are running on our Cloud
Platform-- namely managed VMs
that were running on top of App
Engine and a Redis
Cluster that was
running on top of
Compute Engine--
and using the Datastore
to store data.
That allowed you to save
walks, and then share them
with your friends, and then have
your friends comment on them.
Well, today in this session,
Zero to Hero with Google Cloud
Platform, we're going to take
a look at that application
and do a deeper dive
into how we built it,
using our unified tool
chain, our managed platform.
Kate's going to talk a bit about
how we run Google production
services on your laptop so you
can be an efficient developer.
And then finally, we'll
look at some advancements
we're making in the DevOp
space so that you can actually
debug your application
in production
and feel confident
about what's running.
So to get started,
we need to start
with the foundation, a
cloud platform project.
And that's super simple to do.
All we need to do is bump out
to our developer console here.
We do Create Project.
We'll give it a sample
name, demo name.
We'll call it walkshare10.
And we'll go ahead
and create that.
Now, that's going to take
about 10 to 15 seconds.
And while that
does happen, let's
take a look at
some of the changes
that we've made in our Developer
Console since our Cloud event
back in March.
So the focus has been on
taking the user experience
and really consolidating
it down to the core pieces
of your application.
So as you can see on
the left-hand side,
we have APIs and Auth so that
your application connect back
to Google Cloud services
and other Google services,
as well as third party
applications connecting back
into your application, as
well, via the endpoints
that you might
surface through Cloud
Endpoints or any RESTful style.
We have Monitoring, right?
So a consolidated
view into the metrics
that are coming from your
application-- the performance
of that application as well
as centralized logging,
coming from Compute Engine
and App Engine, which
I'll touch on
throughout the talk.
Source Code for storing your
source code in the cloud,
as well as doing your
builds in the cloud.
Compute, a consolidated home
for both App Engine and Compute
Engine.
And finally, Storage
for all things storage
related, whether it be
non-relational, relational,
or blob data.
And then Big Data for
our analytics tools,
such as BigQuery
and Cloud Dataflow,
that we announced today.
So now we'll see
that our application
has been successfully built.
So simple enough?
Well, actually,
through that process,
within that 10 to
15 seconds, we've
created quite a bit
of infrastructure
for you and on your behalf.
We've created namespaces so that
your application can connect
back to our multi-tenant
services, our cloud services,
via Memcache, Datastore for
storing NoSQL type data, task
queues for communicating
within your application.
We've created those
namespaces for you
so you can securely hook
into those services.
We've given you a
centralized logs repository
so you can funnel all of your
data from your compute back
to one spot, where you
can view it and interact
with it via the Logs API or
through our Developer Console.
We've given you a Git
repository so you can actually
store all your source
code into the cloud,
enable things like
Cloud Debugger,
like you saw today from Greg.
And then we also
give you agents that
are running on top of these
VMs that are hooking back
into all of our monitoring data.
So they're monitoring the
applications that are running,
they're monitoring your
compute, and they're
funneling all of that data
back into the dashboards
that we have.
OK, great.
So now that we've got
this up and running,
we've got our project
created, let's actually
add some source code to it.
And I want to do that
with our Google Cloud SDK.
It's our unified tool
chain that brings together
all the services
within Cloud, be it
App Engine, Compute Engine,
Cloud Storage, Cloud Datastore,
pulls it all into
one unified tool
chain so you have those services
available at your fingertips.
So see that if we bump
out to our terminal
here, I have some local source.
And what I want to do is I
want to take that local source
and push it into the cloud,
and then actually have it built
and be deployed,
and we can check out
our application running.
So this is pretty
straightforward.
I'm going to use our G Cloud
application, or Google Cloud
SDK.
And since I'm terrible about
remembering command line
options, command
line parameters,
I'm happy that they actually
have code completion
and command completion
built into the SDK.
So if I just do a
double tap, I'll
get the commands that I can run.
You know, sometimes
in life, it's
just the little things that
actually make your life much,
much better.
So I do gcloud init, and we'll
use that same application
that we-- same project
that we just built.
All right, and that's
going to go through,
and it's going to create some
local directories for me,
in which lies some metadata
about the Git repository.
All right, let's clear
that for ease of use.
Now, what we'll do is we'll
navigate into that directory,
and we'll copy in our source.
OK, so we get a
Java application,
represented by a pom.xml
file and some source.
What we'll do is we're going
to go ahead and add that.
And commit.
Let's see, initial
commit for the comment.
All right, all looks good.
And then finally, if
we just do a Git push,
it'll push that
up into our Repo.
OK, there we go.
So it's taking my local source
and pushing it into the cloud.
And the idea there
is that we want
you to be a productive
developer and allow
you to use the tools that
you're used to, in this case,
Git, to develop locally
and then finally, run.
And I mean run, I mean in
Google production data centers.
So as this Git push is going
from source into the cloud,
into that Git
repository, we're going
to see that there
are services that
are picking it up and
actually building it.
So let's funnel back over
to our developer console.
And if we go to
our project, we do
a refresh on the Git repository.
OK, so we see my source
code now, up in the cloud.
And you see my last comment,
which was just initial commit.
And then since this
is a Java application,
we need to build it somewhere.
What we'll see is if we click
down into the Releases section
here, we should see a build
that has been kicked off.
Give it just a second.
OK.
There we go.
And actually, by this
time, it's actually
build, tested, and deployed.
So where is it
actually building?
So we saw that we have a
Git repository in the cloud.
I pushed everything up there.
Something had to kick in.
What we're doing
is, on your behalf,
we're spinning up a Compute
Engine virtual machine
that's running Jenkins.
So to do continuous
integration for you,
it's picking up that push,
because there's hooks into it,
it's building on the VM,
it's running my tests.
And if all my tests pass, it
actually does a deploy out
to App Engine.
And we can see that right here.
And if we drill
in, we can see the
build logs and the diff
and everything like that.
So if everything is
working correctly,
we should have a new
version up and running.
And if I go to
walkshare10.appspot.com, voila.
So there's our
application running.
If I click here-- so we'll
post a silly comment.
Good.
Everything is saved.
So now we've pushed
everything into the cloud,
and it's running.
Now, once this is
running at scale,
let's say that we wanted to
do some sentiment analysis
or something on
this application.
So I've got hundreds
of thousands
of comments that are running
in, that are being stored.
And I want to take and do
some sentiment analysis
on those comments
that are coming in.
Now, to do that, I
know that I'm going
to need a bigger,
beefier machine.
I'll need more CPU and
more memory, right?
And furthermore, I'll
need some kind of library
that will allow
me to do analysis
on the streams
that are coming in.
Something like OpenCL,
which is a fantastic
library for doing this.
Now, the problem is that,
historically, App Engine
hasn't supported this.
For security and
scalability reasons,
you're not able to run native
code, so C or C++ code,
or access things like the file
system or the network stack.
It also doesn't have the memory
configurations and the CPU
configurations, the
footprints, that I
need to run sentiment analysis.
At the same time,
though, I don't
want to jump all the way over
into unmanaged infrastructure
as a service and run
all those VMs myself.
So lucky for me that back
in March of this year,
at our Cloud
Platform Live event,
we launched into limited
preview a new feature
called Managed VMs, which
takes the management platform
capabilities of App
Engine and merges those
with the power, the control,
and the flexibility of Compute
Engine, thus providing you
the best of both worlds.
And in the spirit of making
developers highly efficient,
we've made this super
simple for you to get up
and running, to move from
App Engine into Managed VMs.
All you have to do is change
your configuration files.
So here, we're looking at
a Java configuration file.
You set the VM property to true.
Easy enough.
You specify which machine
type you would want.
In this case, we
want an n1-standard,
but actually there's a little
typo in this [? deck. ?]
You actually want a
high CPU machine here.
But the nice thing is
that with this property,
you can specify any Compute
Engine machine type,
both that we have
now and the ones
that we're investing in
in the days in the future
and in the months to come.
And then we need to specify
the number of instances
that we want.
In this case, I just
say that I want five.
You can put whatever
you want to in here.
And furthermore, you
can programmatically
change the number
of instances when
you're running in production.
And then, in the
coming months, we'll
have auto scaling that
will apply to this as well.
So we'll really build out
the complete offering.
At that point in time, you'd
be running in production,
and you'd have access to
those native resources
that I talked about.
You'd have that flexibility
of Compute Engine.
So you could get at the
lower level network stack,
or the file system, you could
run the OpenCL or C or C++
binary that you wanted to
run, and you'd be able to do
the sentiment analysis
that we were looking at.
Now, furthermore, it's
not just about being
able to run these
native libraries
and have access to
the network stack.
This also brings to the front
a new hosting environment,
where we can build new run
times, both internal to Google
and external.
So we won't be constrained to
just having Java and Python
and PHP.
We could look at having Scala
or Haskell or [? Node. ?]
And to prove this
out, we've been
working with internal
teams-- both the Go team
and the Dart team-- that are
both done in the Cloud sandbox,
or down in the sandbox
today, as we speak.
We've worked with them over
the months to build this out
and to actually
have them vet out
this new hosting
environment, where
they can run these run times.
And we're looking to
partner with other people
within the community and
other open source providers
to make this happen.
And so at the end of it, once
you've made your configuration
changes, all you need
to do is save your file,
do another Git commit,
do another Git push,
and you're running
into production.
And when you do that
push, what's nice,
and what is in the spirit
of making developers highly
productive, is that
that actual push, those
I think it was one,
two, three, four, five
lines of configuration,
get pushed out,
and you have managed VMs
running in production.
And what that means
is that we give you
the hosting environment.
So Compute Engine VMs, we make
sure that they're healthy,
and we make sure they put health
checking on them and healing.
We give you a web server,
because after all, you're
serving web traffic.
We give you an application
server to run your application.
We give you a Java Runtime
Environment to run Java.
And then we run all your
third party code as well.
Then we take and install a load
balancer, and wire it all up,
and hook it into
your web servers.
And we configure that all
for you, on your behalf.
You don't have to
specify any of that.
And furthermore, in
this model, what you do
is you get us providing
operating system updates
and security patches for
that hosting environment,
similar to how we do
on App Engine today.
We do colocation and
locality optimizations.
What that means is that
we take all the pieces
of your application
and make sure
that they're running together
in a very highly available way
so that we're minimizing
network latency
and latency within
your application
and giving you very,
very high SLAs.
And then finally, you
get Google as your SRE.
And what does that
last point mean?
That's a great question.
At Google, there's a set
of software engineers
that are tasked with making
sure that services like Search,
and Gmail, and Geo-- they're
ensuring that they have
high uptime and they're running
in a very efficient manner.
And what they do is, with
those SREs, with Managed VMs,
you're getting the same--
they're watching over
your production deployments in
the same manner that they're
watching over Search and then
applying the same monitoring
that they have for App Engine
for years and years and years.
So what that means for
you as a developer is
you focus on your code and
what you want to build.
And when you deploy it
into Google production,
the SREs are watching over
that-- the SREs and a lot
of our services-- to ensure
that you have high uptime
and performance.
So if there's something like
network degradation in a data
center, you don't want
to worry about that.
We got that covered.
If there's some link
between two data centers
that has degraded
performance, you
don't need to worry
about that either, right?
If there's some external
event that are actually
impacting the running
of your applications,
we've got that covered as well.
We've got monitoring
services built into the data
centers that funnel
back into our SREs,
and into our graphs
and our dashboards,
to make sure that everything is
running performantly for you.
Now, with Managed
VMs, one other point
is we're running all of
that inside of containers
on top of Compute Engine.
And we happen to be using
Docker as our technology.
Now, why are we using Docker?
It's pretty cool, right?
Who's heard of Docker
in the crowd today?
Yeah, that's what I thought.
So it's a great
technology, and it
does a lot of amazing things.
But more specifically,
what it does
is it's a tool chain that
gives us static binaries
that our services can
scale up and scale down.
It's like a template
that you can just
go punch out new ones, right?
Give me one more of these,
give me one more these,
give me one more of these.
And since it's
static, we don't have
to do any initialization
when we spin it up.
It's very good for scaling.
Finally, also it
provides portability.
So that which you are building
on your local environment,
we can easily run in production,
and it just moves with you.
And finally, it provides a
container host environment
that allows us to manage
the host environment,
providing those OS updates
and security patches
that I had talked about
before, without impacting
that which is running
inside the container,
concretely, your application.
And for more about how we're
using containers within Google,
be sure to check out these
two sessions on containers
in Google Cloud and
containers in App Engine
over the course of
today and tomorrow.
OK, so just to check in, we've
gone through quite a bit here
in a matter of about
15, 20 minutes.
We've clearly moved
away from the zero stage
and closer to the
hero stage, right?
We've gone through
getting started
and getting something
up and running.
We've gone through
getting some code,
hooking that code up to our
Git repository in the cloud.
We've pushed, we've
seen it build,
and we've deployed
out to production.
We've utilized a new feature
set within Managed VMs.
So I definitely
think we're making
a fair amount of progress here.
But I did mention that we are
going to talk about some code,
and Kate's going
to dive into how
we're doing production of
Google services on your laptop.
So without further ado, I'm
going to hand it over to Kate.
[LIGHT APPLAUSE]
Clap for her, come on.
Kate, Kate, Kate.
[APPLAUSE]
KATE VOLKOVA: So
here, on my laptop,
I've already got the code
for our WalkShare demo.
And it's in the diagram
of the project already,
maybe even more than once today.
So I'm not showing it again.
But just as a quick
reminder, we've
got an Android
mobile application,
and then we've got the
whole bunch of modules
running on App Engine
servers, or on Compute Engine
instances, that prices,
comments, or displays
any other stats for us.
So let's see what we
are going to concentrate
on today, which is
App Engine modules,
and in particular,
your workflow when
developing on our platform.
So you see here, I've
got three modules.
One is a web front-end, written
in Python and JavaScript.
This.
And the second one is the
common server, written in Java,
that runs on Managed VMs.
And the third module
is a server talking
to the [INAUDIBLE]
storage, written in Go.
So to allow you to iterate
more quickly when developing
on our platform, our SDK
provides a set of tools
to emulate App Engine
production environment locally
on your machine.
And as all the other Google
Cloud Platform command line
tools, it is now
bundled under Cloud SDK
and available under
gcloud command.
So let's try to
run that command.
So here, what I passed through
it is just the output level
that I want to see.
Then App preview, seeing that
we're in preview right now.
Then app, that's saying that
it's App Engine component.
Run the command that
I actually want to do.
And then the list of
modules, and they just patch
that tells App
Engine which request
to route to which module.
It's actually already
started, but I
thought it could take
a couple minutes.
So here is the
diagram to explain
what was going to happen.
So when you run gcloud
command, app run command,
we start the development
server for you,
locally, on your machine.
And that development
server is just
a web server that simulates
running App Engine production
environment locally
on your machine.
And by simulating here, I mean
first is enforcing some sandbox
restrictions that
you would have,
running App Engine application
in production, like now
restricted access
to the file system.
Or in second but more--
that seems more important to
me is emulating
all of our services
again, locally, on your machine,
like Datastore or Memcache.
And on top of that, you also
get the local implementation
of admin console that, again,
helps you debugging the app.
So nothing really new yet.
But if you remember,
one of our modules
is a module, running on Managed
VMs and has this magic VM
equals true setting
in App Engine
configuration file, App
Engine [INAUDIBLE] XML.
So how we're going to
emulate that-- I mean,
starting and restarting
several virtual machines,
one for each instance,
on your laptop
would significantly
slow things down, if not
completely kill it.
So here, the technology that is
gaining more and more momentum
lately, called containers,
comes to the rescue.
And we use Docker
containers to provide you
with a local experience when
developing for Managed VMs.
So when you have VM equals
true in your App Engine
configuration file,
development server
will trigger the Docker build
command and build the image
with your code,
or your binaries.
And then it will
run that command
and start the container for
you and start routing requests
from development server
to your container
and to your app running
inside of that container.
And to make this scheme
work on all the platforms
that we support, be that
Linux, Mac, or Windows,
we still have a virtual
machine with that Docker demand
preconfigured out
and running on it.
But just one.
So now that we know what's
supposed to be happening, let's
flip back to the logs
and quickly go over what
I've just talked for you.
So first we see
starting API server,
so we'll get our local Datastore
and Memcache implementation.
Then we are starting
a dispatcher module
and all the other modules.
And here, we are connecting
to the Docker daemon
and starting the
Managed VM module.
So we are building the
image, we are tagging it
as application ID, module
name, and the version.
Then we build that image,
we create a container
from that image, and
we start running it.
We also sent the start
signal to that instance
exactly the same way as
it works in production.
And this time, it even
[? rates ?] 2,200,
which is cool.
So one more thing to note here
that we'll get to a little bit
later is this line,
that we can also
debug, attach the
debugger to our container,
and do some debugging.
So one more thing to see
here is the docker ps command
that just lists all
the containers running
on my machine.
And so I have these containers
running for three minutes.
That's about time
I've been talking.
And we can even get some
logs from that container,
seeing that we are starting
the instance in debug mode,
and forwarded the log somewhere.
Again.
So now we have everything
up and running.
So let's see how it looks like.
Hmm.
Pretty similar to what Chris
just shown in production,
even though it's
locally on my machine.
And again, what I
was talking about
is the local version
of admin console
that lists all of our modules.
We can click on these instances.
This is just a testing
servlet printing out
the Java version of
the comments module.
So we have the standard Java 7.
And then we can do
some more stuff here.
We can see the
indices, for example.
We can change something in
the Datastore, like unknown.
Maybe after this talk
I will be better known,
so let's update this one.
So sometimes little
things like that help us
with debugging when we develop
the application locally.
So let's try to
post a comment now.
Hmm.
Something is definitely wrong.
Chris, I told you not to
touch my code before the demo.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: I sent
you a code review.
KATE VOLKOVA: OK.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: [INAUDIBLE]
KATE VOLKOVA: Well, well.
So I mean-- in normal
life, if something
like that happens in production,
the first thing I would do
is probably go
check the Datastore
if the data is corrupted.
But again, Chris
asked me to show you
how easy the local debugging of
your App Engine module running
inside of the Docker
container can be.
So let's try to do that.
So here I have
the Android Studio
and my project open in here.
And I guess part of that
application is Android.
So we're just
using the same tool
for developing all
of the modules.
And here, let's try to attach
the debugger to our container.
So if you can see that log,
we're attached to the container
right now, and let's try
to post another comment.
That will be boring
comment because it probably
won't work again.
OK, so we've got
some stack trays.
We've got something-- let's
just follow through the methods
and see what we're
trying to add.
OK, we're gonna do some checks.
We're extracting the
parameters of the request.
OK.
Uh-huh.
This line tells me something.
I guess he wants it to rename
the methods and the properties
and didn't rename all of them.
Oh well, let's just
deattach again,
fix it back, and
rebuild the project
and try to post
the comment again.
So let's see if it still
compiles now that I touched it.
OK, success.
Good.
And while we are
restarting that module,
let's all do what I was talking
about, actually looking in
to Datastore and see our
entry with the wrong property.
And let's just click Delete,
and like it never happened.
So back to the console.
The cool thing about
development server
is that it watches for the file
changes or for, in this case,
Java class changes.
And now it is that
something changed.
And we just sent the stop
signal to all the instances
that we had, and then
rebuilt the new image
and created the new
container from it,
and started to forward
requests again.
And apparently, that
didn't quite work.
Let's just rebuild once again.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: So your
VM's up, but it's not
restarting the instances?
Is that it?
KATE VOLKOVA: Ah, yep.
The image got rebuilt,
but it does not
want to restart the
instance right now.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: I
think my bug was
more systemic than you thought.
KATE VOLKOVA: Yeah, I thought
it was so unimportant.
Let me just quickly
go over it again.
Let me just try to
restart everything.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Well,
better to be doing it
locally than in
production, right?
KATE VOLKOVA: Oh well.
You need to have a
backup plan sometimes.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: It's
the demo demons.
KATE VOLKOVA: No, that
would complete [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS RAMSDALE: You're
going to try one more time?
KATE VOLKOVA: Ah, yep.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: So
while she debugs
that, gives it one
more shot, I think
one of the interesting
things here is that when
you think about container
technologies like Docker, one
of the things that they
promote, much like I said,
was the ability to port your
application back and forth.
Well, what's
interesting is if you
use cloud-based services--
so hosted services,
be it our services,
Amazon's services,
whatever they may
be-- if there's
no local story for that, the
portability kind of starts
to break down, right?
So if we just had Datastore in
the cloud and that was it, then
when you say, well, it's great,
I can port my application
from my local environment to
my production environment,
the fact of the matter is that
in your local environment,
if you don't have Datastore
or task queues or Memcache,
you can't actually build
there because you can only
get half the story, right?
So by taking this and making
these production services
available on your laptop
or wherever you're
doing development, really,
it completes the story.
So you really do
have portability.
And it's kind of
crazy, because even
in the Datastore side
of things, I'll never
forget about a year ago--
KATE VOLKOVA: Yeah, I guess
that that will happen right
during the demo.
I need to clean up
some space on my disk.
That's terrible.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: [LAUGHS]
KATE VOLKOVA: While I'm doing
that, you can keep talking.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
Just bat me away
when you're ready.
So the anecdote here was
that about a year ago, I
worked closely with the
Datastore team as well.
And I'll never forget the
tech lead, Alfred Fuller,
came to me, and
he's like, so we're
going to put eventual
consistency-- hold on,
does everybody know what
eventual consistency is?
No?
OK, so it's the idea that
when you run horizontally
scalable services, that
sometimes to get that scale,
the data might
not be consistent.
So you might do a write, and
if you come to another data
center, it might not
have replicated yet.
And that gives
you scale, but you
have to build your
applications around them.
Because if you
expect consistency,
you expect I do a write, and
then I do a read immediately.
And if that's not the
case, then weird things
happen in your application.
I still think it's a pretty
complex concept to grasp.
And so do some of our customers,
because what they were doing
is they were building in
our local environment,
like Kate's trying to demo here.
We didn't have that.
It was strongly inconsistent.
Because after all,
it's on your laptop.
There's no replication of
other data centers, right?
And this kept
impacting customers
when they moved into the cloud.
So that porting from
local to production
was causing discrepancies.
And so Alfred
comes and says, I'm
going to build eventual
consistency into our SDK.
And I was like, you
are out of your mind.
He's like, no, no no.
We're totally going to do it.
And within two
weeks, they basically
mimicked, down to
that level-- anyways.
[APPLAUSE]
KATE VOLKOVA: I
think we really added
a little bit of
excitement into our demo,
and proving that it's all
real and happening right now,
locally, on my machine.
Was not planned.
I got quite a sweat.
OK, so we can develop
locally, debug locally.
So let's try something
a bit cooler now.
As you know, using Managed
VMs, together with App Engine,
allows you any level of
customization that you want.
And you can run any
third party libraries
or call any binaries,
which was not quite allowed
with a classic App Engine.
So let's try something here.
So for those of you who like
the functional style of Java 8
as much as I do, let's try
to insert [INAUDIBLE] here.
Search for COOL STUFF.
And just remove
that old iteration.
Ah, don't break anything again.
OK, so now we've got some Java
8 kind of style code in here.
Here, Chris was
supposed to ask me that,
but App Engine only
supports Java 7.
And my answer to
this would be let's
add a little bit
customization to here.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: So this
was in the same vein
of us saying that how we're
enabled in Go and Dart
and how we could enable
Node and Scala and Haskell.
Kate's just doing this
in terms of App Engine,
or in terms of Java.
So going from Java 7 to
Java 8 is a pretty big move,
but with a few lines
of configuration,
she now has the semantics and
language aspects of Java 8
inside of her application.
KATE VOLKOVA: Yeah, but
more than two lines.
And what I did here is just a
little bit more customization.
And to use instead of our
AppEngine-based Docker
image, the Docker
image that I've just
built before the demo--
oh no, again that
was based on the device.
OK, and hopefully that now
there will be [INAUDIBLE].
It's terrible.
So I was just trying to
remove some containers,
but [INAUDIBLE].
I've removed some images.
Hopefully none of
them are important.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: So
you know when somebody
says they're demoing things
that are hot off the press,
and you guys say this
is hot off the press.
We have early dog fooders that
are trying this out right now.
So I think it takes a lot
of courage to get on stage
and try it out.
Should we call this one?
KATE VOLKOVA: Yeah, I'll try
to fix it and show the rest,
but while you keep
talking a bit more.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Fantastic.
Cool.
So minus the demo demons--
I thought actually
that was some really cool
technology, of taking
Google production services,
moving them into a laptop,
and then taking
technologies like Docker
to enable them so
that you can be
highly efficient as a developer.
And what it hopefully
will show is
how we can take that technology
and allow you to further expand
the languages and run times that
you're using on our platform
as a service
offering App Engine.
And then furthermore,
bringing it all down
into one centralized IDE.
So you notice Kate, if she had
been doing Android development,
she'd do it right there,
inside Android Studio.
So you can build
your mobile client
and build your
back end services,
all within one centralized tool.
And mobile and cloud
working together
is something we're
extremely passionate about.
It's near and dear to our heart.
So you definitely want to
check out these sessions,
if you're interested, over the
course of today and tomorrow.
And by the way, don't worry,
these are all in your schedule.
But they'll also be put up when
we get done with the session.
So I want to talk a bit
about integrated DevOps.
So when you actually move from
your laptop into production,
you do that deployment, your
DevOps don't need to leave you.
They shouldn't
leave you, actually.
In fact, one would say
that it's even more
important to have that
introspection into applications
that are actually
running in production.
Because after all,
it's no longer
a bug that's impacting you
and your other developers that
are building out
the application,
you're talking about bugs
that actually impact your end
users, and then
sometimes your business.
So like in the
case of Search, you
add another hundred
milliseconds of latency,
and it could cost you millions
of dollars in terms of revenue.
So with that, let's
take a look at how
we're doing things within
the Google Cloud Platform,
in terms of DevOps.
Whoops.
Sorry about that.
So I'm going to bump back
down to the console here.
And here.
So the first thing
we'll do is we'll
take a look at our-- yeah,
looking for monitoring data.
Sorry about that.
So first of all, what we
have is integrated monitoring
and metrics for your Managed
VMs and for your compute.
And since we're bringing
together App Engine and Compute
Engine, we're also
bringing together the data
and the monitoring that you
actually need to see as well.
So here I'm looking
at one instance,
and I can see a summary
of overall traffic,
and I can easily
bump back and forth
between the actual
underlying VMs.
So here, I'm seeing
compute statistics,
like CPU utilization
and memory utilization.
But I can also see a summary of
the requests and the response
latency.
So those are things
that you would get out
of your app heuristics.
When you're just
running a raw VM,
all you really see is disk,
network, CPU, and memory.
But when you're running
a full on stack,
the full on stack that I
had mentioned when you move
a Managed VM into
production, you
get that web server,
that application server,
that web serving stack
that you want to see
and have introspection into.
And so we're doing that.
Now, with Managed
VMs, what we're doing
is we're moving and creating
a homogeneous fleet of compute
for you.
And that homogeneous
fleet of compute
is managed by our
services and by our SREs,
as I kind of mentioned
going through here.
Now, for those services
and those teams to do that,
that fleet of compute needs
to be hermetically sealed.
Meaning we can't
just let-- we don't
allow developers to willy-nilly
go into the machines
and create what we call a
kind of special snowflakes.
Because if you
have, for example,
a hundred VMs running,
and VM 45 and 46
are slightly different
than the rest,
and you go try to manage
all those together,
it becomes highly,
highly complicated.
And you can imagine, as you
scale up to tens of thousands,
it gets even worse.
Now, given that, that
those are locked down
and you don't have root
access into those VMs,
one might say, well,
hmm, that kind of poses
a non-trivial problem of how
do I get data off of those VMs,
right?
Like logs.
So how do I get request logs
or application logs or system
logs, or even third party
logs, off those VMs?
Well, the logs are on
the VMs, and the VMs
are funneling all of that
traffic and all those log data
back to a centralized logging
repository that I mentioned
in one of the earlier slides.
And what that means for
you is, as a developer,
you come back to
our console here,
and you'll see that we have
integrated logs access.
So it will allow you to
do things like filter logs
by log source, by
log request type.
You can filter by
errors-- in a second.
You can actually do debugging
of the request logs--
the application logging--
in terms of the request.
So you can see what
the application
is doing based on what
the user is requesting.
And finally, you can see those
third party logs as well.
So let's say if we bump
into-- let me actually
pick a different one here.
There we go.
Sorry.
Just was a little bit delayed.
So here what we can see is
we see the App Engine logs.
And if I filter through
these, I can probably find one
that's-- Info.
Yeah.
If I click on the Info one.
So here, what I'm seeing is that
this is a request back to the--
that's not necessarily
that interesting.
Well, you can see it's a request
back to the _ah/remote_api
path.
That's the request that came in.
And what you see
highlighted in the yellow
there is actually what the
application was logging.
I could actually sort by status.
[INAUDIBLE] Don't
see any errors.
Look at that, I actually have
no bugs in my code over here.
And then, if I come
down to Compute Engine.
I had mentioned that a
portion of the WalkShare demo
was actually running
a Redis cluster that
allows you to do streaming,
with some indexing in there.
And so we're doing is actually
running-- I can show you
the Redis logs here.
So I pull that off and filter
by something as simple as Redis.
Yeah, OK.
So there you can see
all the Redis logs.
The idea is we've
consolidated it down
into one unified logs viewer.
And we're pulling those
logs off of the machines.
Then finally, in
the topic of-- so
I mentioned that these VMs
are locked down by default.
No root access is available.
We realized that
there's times when
you need to get to
the underlying VM.
You might have a CPU spike.
You might have an out of memory
error-- who knows, right?
And after many years of being
a developer and building
developer tools, I know
there's one thing that you do,
is that you have to
know when to get out
of the way of the
developer and let
them do what they need to do.
So in the spirit of that,
we've made it super easy
to get to the underlying
VM-- to break glass and get
to the Compute Engine VM.
So if I come into-- I think I
had this lined up over here.
If I come into our
versions-- there we go.
So here we have a Managed
VM that's running.
Click on that.
OK, so what I'm doing
is I'm looking, again,
at the monitoring of metrics
for this particular Managed
VM, which I'm only
running one of.
It could be 5 or 10, depending
on how I change my properties.
But what you see over
here is this SSH tab.
And I'll come back to
what's in this dialogue,
but I'm going to work
through this dialogue.
And it's going to
open up root access
and SSH connectivity
back into the VM.
And furthermore, the developer
console makes it super easy,
because we now support SSH
in a tab in your browser.
And what you see here
is that obviously we're
enabling root access, but
we're starting the SSH service.
And we're enabling access.
And so now I'm actually
in the VM-- I really
apologize for how small this is.
OK, bear with me.
Sorry, it's super small.
But I'm actually
in the VM, and I
can do simple things
like run netstat.
I can run PS.
I can run top if I want to.
All the commands that are
available to you in a VM.
And finally, I can exit,
and I'm good to go.
And all you need to do
to get that thing back
into being managed
is switch from user
managed to Google managed.
Now, real quickly,
what does that do?
So when we switch it from
Google managed to user managed
and we enable root access,
we're giving you access
to the VM, in which case
you can SSH in and make
any changes you want to.
After all, it's your VM.
But by giving you root access
and letting you make changes,
we want to remove our
management processes
because it will conflict
with each other.
They could, right?
You can make all kinds of
kernel changes, who knows what.
So we move it out of that pool.
And furthermore, we take it
out of the health checking pool
as well.
Because the last
thing we want to have
happen is our health checker
to our health checking service
to think that the VM
is actually unhealthy,
because you're debugging
it or something,
and shoot it and terminate
it, in which case
that's a terrible developer
experience for you.
So we make it super simple.
You move back and forth
between user managed
and Google managed.
So great.
If you want to
see more on DevOps
and how we're working on
monitoring and our work
with Stackdriver, check
out these sessions today
and tomorrow.
OK, so to recap,
I definitely think
that we've gone from
the zero to the--
we're now to the
hero stage, right?
We've gone through
getting started,
creating an application
in our cloud platform.
We've deployed some code.
We've done a build in the cloud.
We've walked through how
to build an Android client.
We've talked about
how to do integrated
DevOps and centralized
logging and monitoring,
and get access to
the underlying VM,
and to see all of the
metrics and the monitoring
that's coming from our VMs.
So yeah, I definitely think
we've reached the hero stage.
There were some bumps along
the way, but we got there.
And I see that
we're short on time,
so I'm going to wrap it up here.
Did you--
KATE VOLKOVA: Unless we want to
talk through the development--
through the deployment
step for Managed VMs.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: I think
we're kind of out of time.
KATE VOLKOVA: Then forget.
CHRIS RAMSDALE: I'm sorry.
So just a real quick recap.
If it wasn't clear,
developer productivity
is near and dear to our hearts.
It's something we're very,
very passionate about.
And the way we view
that is making getting
started super easy to do
so that you get progress
in the order of minutes
and not necessarily hours.
We believe in a
unified tool chain
so that you have access
to all of our services
at your fingertips, and
they're easy to use.
We want to move Google
production services
and make them available
on your laptops
so that it's easy to debug
and to iterate and be agile.
And then finally, we want
integrated DevOps to follow you
into the cloud so
that production
is no longer a black box.
And you can have the
monitoring and introspection
you need so that you can make
change and actually impact
your application.
So again, thanks for
spending time with us today.
We appreciate it.
And if you're
interested, there's
going to be some other
sessions talking about some
of the things we covered today
in our Zero to Hero talk.
So thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]